[Music]
in the previous video we saw just how
important low-latency is when creating
interactive audio experiences but how
can you actually achieve this in your
app in this video I'll show you how the
oboe library helps you to create a low
latency audio stream for playing sound
you can play sound through a number of
different audio devices such as the
built-in speakers wired headphones USB
audio devices or over Bluetooth an audio
stream is used to move data from your
app to an audio device so that it can be
played to create an audio stream we use
an audio stream builder this allows us
to set properties on the stream it's
best to leave most properties
unspecified to allow OBO to pick the
optimal values for the default audio
device however to create a stream with
the lowest possible latency there are a
few properties which we should always
set the performance mode should be set
to low latency and the sharing mode
should be set to exclusive once the
stream properties have been set we can
open the stream by passing a reference
to an audio stream pointer be sure to
check the stream open successfully
otherwise you won't have a valid stream
object if there was a problem you can
convert the error to a human readable
string using convert to text in fact
convert to text can be used to convert
many OBO objects to text once the stream
has been successfully opened you can
start it asynchronously you can now send
data to the audio device to put data
into an audio stream we can either write
directly into it or have the audio
stream request data using a callback
callbacks give us the lowest latency so
it's best to use them for interactive
audio apps to create a callback object
sub class audio stream callback and
override the on audio ready method this
method is called when the audio stream
requires more data it has three
parameters a pointer to the audio stream
object a container array which we can
write our audio data into this has type
void star because the format of the
audio stream can either be 16-bit
integers or floats it's up to us to cast
to the correct
lastly num frames tells us how many
frames of audio are required each frame
contains one or more samples the number
of samples will depend on the streams
channel count for example a stereo
stream has two samples per frame one for
the left channel and one for the right
channel num frames also tells us the
maximum time we have to create the data
failure to supply data within this time
is known as an under run as an example
if our audio stream has a sample rate of
48,000 samples per second and 192 frames
are requested this gives us 4
milliseconds to create this data in the
real world we want to keep well under
this deadline to allow for system
overhead and late callbacks to give you
the best chance of meeting this audio
deadline on audio ready is called on a
high priority system thread which means
it won't be preempted by lower priority
threads but it's critical that you don't
do too much work or block inside this
method more detailed guidance on what
you should and shouldn't do here can be
found in the full guide to ovo on github
inside on audio ready we write the
requested number of audio frames into
the audio data array this could be
generated using digital synthesis or be
supplied from pre-recorded audio data
finally return a data callback result
this can either be continued which
indicates that we want the callbacks to
continue or stop which indicates that
the stream should stop with no more
callbacks
once you've finished creating your
callback object you can link it to your
stream using the builder we created
earlier there's one final step we need
to take to ensure our audio stream has
the lowest possible latency setting its
buffer size the audio streams buffer
size affects the time it takes for an
audio frame to travel through the stream
to the audio device the larger the
buffer the longer it takes and the
higher the latency an optimally sized
buffer provides a good trade-off between
latency and under on protection the
buffer size must be a multiple of the
streams burst size which is the number
of frames the audio device consumes in a
single read a good rule of thumb is to
use twice this burst size
this means that if occasionally we miss
our audio callback deadline the user
will not hear an audio glitch as long as
the next callback runs on time use get
frames per burst to get the burst size
and set buffer size in frames to set the
buffer size now that all the stream
properties are set we can start the
stream callbacks will start immediately
and once you finish with the stream
remember to close it after you close a
stream it cannot be accessed any more
you should now have everything you need
to play audio using a low latency audio
stream for a working example check out
the hello oboe sample on github which
shows you how to create a simple
synthesizer app it also demonstrates how
to handle audio device changes such as
when the user connects their headphones
a link can be found below in the next
episode I'll show you how to record
sound through a microphone using low
latency input streams that's all for now
so good luck and go make some noise
[Music]